(snarling)
(yelling)
(banging)
(banging and thudding)
(snarling)
(drilling)
(yelling)
(panting)
- Oh, that's a bad one.
(swoosh) (tongue in cheek music)
(swoosh)
(growling)
(engine roaring)
(bang, thud) - Get in!
(tongue in cheek music)
- We ran over some fun stuff.
- Okay, help me get it off
and let's see what's going on.
(crunching noise)
(growling)
- Ew.
(growling and screeching)
- Well that explains the pull to the left.
(Swoosh)
(Slushing) (swoosh)
(gun fire)
(ding)
(dramatic music)
(slashing) (cracking)
(swoosh) (swoosh)
(growling) - Mack
(gun fire)
(groaning)
(thud)
(growling)
(gun fire)
(crunching)
(screaming) - Oh my.
(munching)
(jazzy music) (swoosh) (swoosh)
(crackling)
(growling)
(buzzing)
(swoosh) (swoosh)
- Z, (drilling) I don't
have time for this.
(drilling continues)
(pop)
(beeping)
(whirring)
(zapping)
(swoosh)
(screaming)
(growling)
(splashing)
(crowd growling) (swoosh)
- Got an idea.
Out of my way Doc I need that cheese.
- Oh come one Ward can't a man eat
a giant cheese wheel in peace.
(growling)
- No.
Remember Philly.
(whoosh) (tires screeching)
(snap)
(ding) (splat)
(dong) (splat)
(whirring)
- What happened in Philly.
- You'll see.
(grunting)
- Okay. - Alright.
- You ready. Alright one, two, three.
(rumbling)
(grunting)
(squishing)
(thudding)
- Damn.
(growling)
(rumbling)
(squishing) (grunting)
- How long do you think it'll go.
- It can go awhile.
I'm pretty sure it's all down hill
from here to the Mississippi.
(growling) (squishing)
(jazzy music)
(growling and squishing)
(moo)
(roaring)
(jazzy music)